when you were in film school what were
some of the things the teachers did that
you said you know what this really works
for me and if I ever become a teacher I
want to emulate that and then on the
reverse that it sort of shut you down
one of the most important things that
happen to me in film school was I had a
professor who introduced me to the idea
that art could be about process not
result and he showed a series of
experimental films that honestly even
narrative films that were built around a
way of working or an approach or a
system and the idea that you could do
that and then be open to the result and
I don't make films that are as
experimental as that but that overall
idea it just changed my entire way of
thinking and I'm so grateful that
someone introduced me to that idea you
know we live in a media environment
where I think we're very result oriented
you know how did how much money this
film make what people think of it or the
reviews that kind of stuff and as an
artist I really realized I have to be
happy with the process to and to explain
have a journey in the process so that
was super important and I definitely
also learned that I had I had professors
who were super interested in engaging
what was new and risky and exciting I
did also encounter though a certain sort
of skepticism towards new technology and
I actually really promised myself that I
wasn't going to be someone who when the
new thing came along I would grumble
about it and ignore it I I remember some
minority of them but a few professors
that are like really being against
digital cameras for example they just
didn't like them and they weren't that
great at the time but it was just so
clear to me they would obviously get
better you know and here we are years
later and I love film but we have great
digital cameras too and so I actually
had that experience literally happen to
the professor several years ago I got
access to an oculus rift Developer Kit
put on the headset and my instant
reaction was like look like I don't like
this every tool of cinema is gone to me
I don't have a frame I don't have
editing you know I don't know if
lighting that much and I was like I
don't wanna do anything do with that and
thankfully in that moment I was like
wait wait you're being that old group of
professors do that and so instead I
threw myself into it and I've done a lot
of work in VR now and honestly I spent
long amount of time not liking it but
still doing it but I was just convinced
there's gotta be something to it and now
I'm at the point where as I've now fully
understood it to be different from film
I do like some things about it but for
sure I had to overcome a lot of my like
grumpy old dinosaur filmmaker sort of
attitude to sort of see what was good
about it what about that your work is
going to invoke either not not dislike
but anger and some people like I'm
thinking of Chris burden I don't know if
you saw that's not you know you did the
LACMA lights and yeah he did a lot of
experimental stuff yeah that made people
angry you know and and he's not the only
artist but and being okay with that I
like the idea of movies that provoke
questions and provoke a response and I'm
perfectly okay people not liking the
movies you know if someone yeah it isn't
their cup of tea if they have an
objection to it I will say like I don't
know that I'm a place in my life where I
want to make a movie that I think will
be consciously hurtful to anyone and I
do think about that for sure like
there's a line I think between provoking
deep questioning or challenging dominant
ideas and then there's another level
which is like yeah I but what I don't
want to do is be hateful or hurtful and
I don't think that I am but like I do
think about that so I'm excited for
people to debate the movies and I'm
excited for people to sort of engage
with them and I'm even okay with people
who are like you know I didn't really
like it I think that that to me that
doesn't impact my artistic choices and I
like filmmakers who do that - there are
filmmakers who I respect whose movie
that actually optically like you know
and and I'm glad they exist I think for
me the only thing that I'm not really
seeing is where I fit we cross the line
between you know expressing alternate
ideas to like essentially being you know
purple and now - Debbie do you prepare
your students for that because it's like
I'm gonna date myself again Gen X we
didn't have we had party lines you can
call party line talk to me well you
didn't have social media where you could
say I hated this I hate the filmmaker
you're awful and now that's a very real
of our culture even if it's just someone
that just wants to invoke an emotion in
the filmmaker yeah I mean I think that
the the social media environmentally the
hardest for those of us that didn't come
of age in it like you know I when I
started a filmmaker as a filmmaker it
was just beginning right the Silicon
Valley explosion was just happening and
so for me like yeah it is a lot have to
definitely sort of remind myself anytime
I go on Twitter there is a chance that
someone is just gonna tell me they hate
my movie you know actually doesn't
happen that often it's like oh maybe
only one or two times but yeah for sure
you have to balance if emotion when you
hear that but when I watch my students I
think the truth is it's less that
they're better at navigating that but
more that that's just a fact of life for
them in all aspects of life that like
everything they you know that they do is
in some ways always you know subject to
a lot of different commentary or
judgment or ideas and so I think I don't
see them as like particularly sort of
thinking about that being unique to
their filmmaking experience as it is
just reflective of their life experience
interesting so maybe older people myself
maybe part of them we're having a hard
time interesting okay well I'm the I
feel that way
you